[Music]
good morning Hank it's Wednesday October
10th hey great video yesterday your card
metaphor was really effective and it
reminded me that indeed you should not
elect someone just based on whether or
not they would be a good poker player
you have to vote for people at least in
part because of which cards they're
showing you that is what they say
they're going to do and how they say
they're going to get it done the only
problem with your theory Hank is that it
supposes that politicians are basically
honest people and will do the things
that they say they will do when in fact
politicians as a class are slightly more
dishonest than poker players so many
politicians would be like hey look how
good my hand is I'm going to avoid
nation-building I'm not going to engage
in pre-emptive war I'm going to help the
United States break its addiction to
foreign oil and then you're like wow the
King of Hearts sounds like a really
great card and you elect it and it's
like just kidding I'm the Joker by the
way Hank for helping me with that joke
I'd like to thank my 2004 vote Kerry
playing cards so Hank I think that's why
it's important to pay attention to a
politician's character so you can be
reasonably sure that they're going to do
the things that they say they're going
to do and not become some belligerent
anti intellectual mean headed Decepticon
named George Bush but anyway Hank all
that said I like John Edwards I am now
equally for John Edwards and Barack
Obama so you've won that part of the
feud but my dear brother there is one
part of the feud you will never win and
that is the fight between zombies and
unicorns I think I've come up with a
foolproof argument against unicorns
however unfortunately that foolproof
argument is only for people who have
read Harry Potter 7 or who don't mind if
I spoil it for them if you do not want
to know spoilers for Harry Potter 7 you
should turn off this video right now
although honestly Hank if there's anyone
who's managed to avoid Harry Potter 7
spoilers for this long I would like to
find out where they live so that I can
go there in the event of a nuclear
holocaust because it's the safest place
in the world
ok everybody who hasn't read Harry
Potter 7 is gone and I am now speaking
only to Harry Potter nerds my argument
against unicorns is entitled why do you
guys hate talks so much Hank here's how
it breaks down in order for any of the
things that happen in Harry Potter to
happen Voldemort has to not die before
Harry Potter starts and in order for
that to happen Voldemort has to drink
the blood of unicorns which allows him
to live but also makes him like half man
half
or whatever ergo Hank unicorns are
responsible for Voldemort survival what
I'm saying Hank is that unicorns saved
Voldemort and then Voldemort's war
resulted in the death of stalks now Hank
I am NOT an expert in Aristotelian logic
but I'll say this
if unicorns led to Voldemort which led
to Tonks is death and you like unicorns
you killed Tonks not to mention Hedwig
so Hank look I'm not defending zombies
I've never tried to defend zombies
they're disgusting but zombies didn't
kill Tonks I mean Hank you say that if
you were walking through a forest you'd
rather come across a unicorn than a
zombie and that seems logical until you
consider that all they ever do in Narnia
is impale people and all they do in
Harry Potter is save villains I mean
let's face it Hank unicorns are really
good at killing people whereas zombies
are only good at making people under a
hank that I don't want to be Undead but
I also don't want to be really dead
which is what unicorns make you Hank I
hope all is well in Montana and I'll see
you tomorrow
PS everybody send positive thoughts to
secret siblings Adam and Ava and their
cat PPS hey Hank Looking for Alaska or
as it's known in Australia Looking for
Alaska is a finalist for the inky's
award any nerdfighters under 25 can vote
link here or maybe here or possibly
there